ce fut une icône à travers l'histoire pour de bonnes et de mauvaises raisons.
Les premiers dont nous avons retrouvé la trace
viennent de la Grèce ancienne et de la Rome antique.
Au Moyen-Âge, beaucoup de moines
portaient des vêtements ressemblant à des capes avec des capuches,
des pulls à capuche.
Au XVIIe siècle, les dames portaient des pulls à capuche
pour se cacher quand elles allaient retrouver leur amant.
Et puis, bien sûr, il y a les légendes, il y a l'imaginaire.
Il y a l'image du pull à capuche liée à la sinistre faucheuse.
Il y a l'image du pull à capuche liée au bourreau.
Il y a le côté sombre du pull à capuche.
L'incarnation moderne du pull à capuche --
un vêtement fait généralement d'un pull en coton,
qui a une capuche attachée avec un cordon,
parfois avec une poche marsupiale --
a été introduite dans les années 30 par Knickerbocker Knitting Company.
Maintenant appelée Champion.
C'était prévu pour tenir chaud aux athlètes.
Bien sûr, c'était un vêtement si fonctionnel et confortable
qu'il a rapidement été adopté partout par les ouvriers.
Puis, vers les années 80, il a également été adopté
par les danseurs de hip-hop et de breakdance, les skaters
et a revêtu ce genre de culture des jeunes de la rue.
Il était à la fois super confortable,
parfait pour la rue
et avait comme valeur ajoutée l'anonymat
quand vous en aviez besoin.
Puis il y a Mark Zuckerberg,
qui défie les conventions des tenues respectables pour les hommes d'affaires.
De façon intéressante, c'est une façon de montrer comment le pouvoir a changé.
Avec un costume deux pièces, c'est le garde du corps.
La personne qui a vraiment du pouvoir
porte un pull à capuche, un t-shirt et un jean.
Il est facile de penser aux aspects physiques du pull à capuche.
Vous pouvez immédiatement penser à la capuche mise
et ressentir cette chaleur, cette protection,
mais en même temps,
vous en ressentez également les aspects psychologiques.
Pensez à enfiler un pull à capuche,
soudainement, vous vous sentez plus protégé,
vous avez l'impression d'être dans votre propre coquille.
Nous savons ce que le pull à capuche a endossé comme signification
ces dernières années aux États-Unis.
Quand Trayvon Martin, un gamin afro-américain de 17 ans,
a été tué par un voisin justicier
et que des marches de « millions de pulls à capuche »
ont eu lieu à travers les États-Unis
où les gens portaient des pulls avec la capuche mise
et ont marché dans les rues contre ce genre de préjugés.
Cela n'arrive pas si souvent
qu'un vêtement ait tant de symbolisme et d'histoire
et qu'il englobe autant d'univers différents
que le pull à capuche.
Comme tous les vêtements,
particulièrement tous les vêtements vraiment utilitaires,
son concept est très simple.
Mais en même temps,
tout un univers de possibilités y est rattaché.